[Musique]
merci
merci beaucoup alors je me trouvais en
face de génocide mais sans le savoir
ça c'est rwanda 1994 c'est moi dans le
photo dans une église pleine des
cadavres je vous ai agi avec deux autres
journalistes
on est venu dans une église dont qui
s'appelle ni à rambouillet au milieu de
la jungle et là il ya des scènes
horribles qui a été devant nous il ya
des milleirs des femmes des hommes des
enfants massacrés des corps décomposé
son bras sans jambes certains s'entêtent
c'était comme un film d'horreur je pris
des notes des photos mais sans
comprendre qui est l'ampleur de cette
grande catastrophe
ces quelques mois après où quelques
années après que le monde a compris que
c'était un génocide un des pires dans
l'histoire moderne
huit cent mille morts c'était aussi les
reportages les plus difficiles demandons
troublant pendant mon carrière de
presque 30 ans concours cependant
étrangères mais c'est aussi un exemple
qui illustre bien les risques on doit
prendre comme des correspondants
étrangères sur le terrain au rwanda je
vous ai agi avec les guérillas qu'on y
aurait pris les terrains ils sont
jongler avec le grenade en au visage
on a traversé des villages brûlés avec
des pièges mortels nous sont tombés
malades
magimel arrière très grammont dans d
autres conflits il ya d'autres risques
comme ici c'est en série c1 à l'ept dans
le passé ou bosnie colombie irak
là il ya d autres risques ça peut être
des mines des ravisseurs des attaques
des attentats des maladies il ya souvent
ou presque partout des risques pour nous
aujourd'hui aussi les journalistes sont
devenus
des cibles dans les conflits dans une
manière qui n'était pas le cas il ya 10
ans ou 20 ans bien sûr on est bien
préparé et protégé on porte souvent les
gelées par balles on a des cours pour
apprendre comment on peut soigner des
blessures
on apprend même comme on doit parler
avec ses ravisseurs
par exemple on doit jamais parlé de
l'argent avec ses ravisseurs mais plutôt
football mais partout où on va il ya ces
risques on peut pas les éviter on doit
prendre est allé s'évaluer alors c'est
pas que les risques pour nous les
reporter sur si les risques pour les
autres dans les conflits les témoins les
gens qui vivent dans les guerres un
exemple ici c'est à la fille très
spécial et je la rencontrais en séries
on enlève l'année passée à la et passa
vrai nom sont vraiment et l histoire
très dramatique
il ya un bond qui est tombé sur sa
maison on allait qu elle a eu de
brûlures jusqu'à 70% sur son corps et
son visage elle était défiguré
complètement mais elle a miraculeusement
pu survivre
alain et ses parents me racontait des
atrocités qu'elle a régime a commis par
exemple ces bombes qui tombent bien sûr
sa maison qui a détruit sa vie pour
toujours dans une manière mais elle est
en vie mais si j'aurais écrit les
commentaires avec les vrais noms d'allah
et ses parents j'ai mis leur vie en
danger
le lendemain la régime peuvent frapper
quelqu'un de la région peut frapper la
porte pour les enlever aux mêmes les
exécuter et comme journaliste dont les
situations pareilles il faut toujours
penser à ça il faut toujours penser aux
victimes et leur sécurité parce que nous
les reporters nous quittons mais eux ils
restent
il faut les protéger c'est très
importante
alors et un autre risque aussi
correspondance est un peu différente ça
parce que ça c'est les risques de ne pas
pouvoir retourner dans un pays pour
faire des reportages
si j'écris des choses qu'ils ont trop
critiques contre un gouvernement ou un
régime
la prochaine fois ils vont je veux pas
avoir une vie ça ils vont baigner visa
pour entrer dans le pays
ça c'est un an il nous place du ressort
des listes noires on dit entre les
journalistes et ses grandes l'aiment
parce que je veux écrire la vérité et à
raconter tout ce que je vois me dans le
même temps je vais pouvoir aussi pouvoir
et tourne dans le pays parce
qu'autrement il ya aucune inflation qui
sort ce un trou noir
un exemple pour moi c'est irak
je voyageais beaucoup en irak pendant la
dictature de saddam hussein et une fois
j'ai écrit un article sur un massacre
dans le sud je savais que c'était très
sensible mais j'ai senti que non il faut
que j'ai écris c'est quand même très
importante
le monde doit connaître et mon journal
on a décidé on va publier et je payer le
prix je me trouvais de la liste noire
je ne pouvais pas rentrer rentrer en
irak pendant trois ans mais c'est un
choix et je ne regarde pas après il ya
des risques qui on ne veut pas prendre
les moments qu'on dit non et je réduis à
leone libéria pour couvrir la maladie et
bola il ya quelques années on a discuté
beaucoup au journal c'est dans les
débuts de la maladie on savait pas
exactement les risques
tout le monde était effrayée finalement
j'ai décidé que je vais pas je ne peux
pas y aller je veux pas prendre c'est
triste pour pour ma famille pour mes
enfants pour moi même même pour le
journal on peut se poser la question
mais qu'on ne peut aller en irak et au
rwanda et en séries mais pas aller pour
couvrir un maladie mais c'est différent
parce que dans une situation comme syrie
l'ennemi est visible il est là hec le
front est là bas l'onu est là bas les
réfugiés sont là bas c'est beaucoup plus
clair dans les situations avec les
mollahs l'ennemi était invisible dans
l'air et c'est un risque et cette fois
on pouvait pas prendre alors la question
est pourquoi je fais ce travail pourquoi
je prends ces risques dans mon métier
dans mon profession est ce que ça change
quelque chose
est ce que mes reportages a un impact je
vais vous présenter rousseff a voté fin
il a 17 ans c'est un réfugié syrien que
je rencontrais au liban l'année passée
il aussi un histoire très dramatique
il ya un bond qui tombe sur lui qu il
est en train de rentrer de l'école on
syrie tout est devenu noir il se
réveille il paraplégique sa mère maïs à
la privée s'efface le dos d'une anne la
traversée de montagnes entre et la syrie
et liban pendant une nuit en hiver ils
sont payer des passeurs c'était un
voyage épouvantable et pendant ce voyage
plaque en métal est cassé dans le dos
sur le dos des héros syfy et quand il
est arrivé au liban il a une grosse
douleur il a besoin en opération en
urgence n'y a personne qui pouvait le
faire et la famille a pas de l'argent
j'ai écrit un article sur lui et j'étais
étonné des réactions de mes lecteurs lui
des centaines de mails et finalement un
groupe s'est mis ensemble et sont payés
l'opération pour syfy qui a sauvé sa vie
et ça c'est pour moi très important ça
montre que le journalisme dangereuse
avec des risques
sur le terrain peut faire une différence
pas seulement pour pour vous les
lecteurs qu'ils vont comprendre mieux qu
est ce qui se passe dans le monde mais
aussi pour les gens pour les victimes
dans les guerres et des conflits et pour
moi ça c'est très important
alors aujourd'hui ça c'est beau ça est
fâché de cette photo il ya quelques
jours il est débout il a des mains et
protéines il commence à prendre un
marché c'est fantastique c'est
magnifique mais la question reste
pourquoi je fais ce travail pourquoi je
prends ces risques
elle se sont cassés comme journaliste
international si on doit couvrir les
conflits et les guerres
on doit se déplacer sur le terrain c'est
notre responsabilité
on doit voir avec nos propres yeux
qu'est ce qui se passe pour vous
raconter on doit parler avec touches ont
essayé d'être voir donner aux voix aux
victimes qui sont souvent oubliés mais
parfois je la liste sont pas sur le
terrain dans les guerres ces histoires
vont pas être est racontée les risques
sont juste trop grande et aucune
articles ou qu'une histoire mérite de
mourir
merci
[Applaudissements]